so this morning we're gonna kick off
something a little different it's not
going to be a straight QA I think I'm
it's probably gonna be even more
enjoyable we're gonna do interactive Q&A
with Peter Wang Peter Wang is the
co-founder and CEO of anaconda I don't
know if he really needs much more
introduction than that I think a lot of
people know and love Peter
so please we're really stressing lets us
be interactive I'll just start a
discussion and I'll kick it over thank
you for that very kind introduction and
just to reiterate what he was saying all
of these meetups in these areas start
with one or two people so don't don't
ever feel like oh it's just me or just
like you know the Python Python
community started with me grabbing beers
the two other people one guy who was
moving to the west coast and he handed
me over the duties of hey you on this
Meetup think is like no one ever comes
and there's just three of us here at the
ginger man and that's now you know like
5,000 people or so what's the latest
Jacob what's the latest registration
count yeah 6600 people registered in
Austin Python now granted took like
whatever 13 shares or something but in
all these places I encourage you to
think about you know how to get involved
and be realistic about your time
obviously but the community grows as the
result of efforts of folks like yourself
you know really just starting the ball
rolling so with that I'm open for
questions about anything and everything
alright you know microphone to him
name's Travis Travis and he didn't
actually planned me here this is a tell
me a little bit about how did putty get
started under your perspective on that I
don't think you know I haven't actually
heard your perspective on how to
probably get started
oh you haven't I think that you've
gotten sick of hearing me tell the story
right now but actually it's actually
possibly haven't ever heard me give it
this way so we were in the spring of
2012 we just started the continuum
analytics which we would now renamed
anaconda and I realized that
there were a lot of people interested in
the topic and excited about the topic of
using Python for data analysis now Wes
had released pandas about a year ago a
year part at that point the ipython
notebook had just come out in the
previous year in 2011 and so there was a
lot of activity starting to swirl around
this and it felt to me like keeping all
of these things under the SyFy brand
would be challenging because it should
be no surprise to most people here in
today's world in business scientific
stuff sounds very geeky and niche but
data analysis is cool especially around
that time big data was kind of we're
reaching peak Hadoop at the time and the
second derivative flattened out with the
first derivative you know still going
strong but but I decided that you know
we wanted to pull people together who
are interested and almost on a whim I
was like you know this just fits Python
data pie data let's call that and
surprisingly no one has squatted the
github repo like it was just not even
there so I was like great cools the
register the domain did all this other
stuff and pulled the other little
workshop in Mountain View Google hosted
us Julie Steele who's a riley the time
helped organize and get some resources
around and we just had a really
fantastic little workshop of like 60 or
70 people at that workshop several
things didn't happen number one
guiteau's Guido
Guiteau stopped by because he was still
at Google at the time and he wasn't we
didn't formally invite him we didn't
think he had the time or the interest
but he actually came by very nicely and
then we did a sit-down with him and that
was it was in that moment that Travis
and others of Fernando and others
approached him about look can you please
help us fix Python packaging that was
2012 and we'd already been banging on
Python package for 10 years at that
point all right can you please help us
fix it he's like you know it's just it's
possible that the needs of packaging for
the scientific and numerical community
are just too exotic you should fix it
yourselves you should do your own thing
and so that was actually the not the
cover but that gave us were like okay
fine so now we're gonna just do our own
thing we can do that and the other thing
that happened at that point was there
was a talk by Chris Miller about disco
which is a framework for doing MapReduce
on top of Erlang in Python it was
released by Nokia it was interesting
thing but that was again peak Hadoop
ever
wanted everyone's talking with MapReduce
and so we thought okay we have a Python
native framework for doing this but then
it occurred to me you know building on
the packaging issues looking how hard it
was just to get a basic Python install
of ipython notebook in everyone
everyone's computers for that workshop I
turn to Travis and I said you know what
we should there's no if we have this
much trouble shipping sci-fi matplotlib
to everyone there's no way we're getting
Erlang and and this like Python
MapReduce there's just no way right and
that was I think before that was before
ipython notebook the the conversion the
MB convert had a hard dependency on
haskell right so there's even before
that so anyway so I was like we need to
create a new distribution of Python for
data analysis or big data and it's a big
snake so we should call anaconda and
that's actually it was at that workshop
that was all that was March 2012
long-winded answer to a very simple
question but thank you for listening
what do you hope to accomplish at akanda
in 2020 a great question thank you in
2020 so I just took over CEO two months
ago and 2020 a lot of big things are
happening so we for the company itself I
know we're launching a new product and
in January we'll have a kind of bigger
announcement around that so I hope for
that product launch to be successful
partnerships around to be successful I
would like to figure out ways that we
can create deeper strategic partnerships
with other major players in the industry
and help bring them to the community
because I one of the things that that's
become apparent to me is that we can try
our darndest to you know pay for
open-source devs and to sponsor this and
sponsor that but we at the end of the
day it's we're limited by how much
dollars we have but like a transistor
our little bit of current might unlock a
much bigger amount of current if we put
it in the right way and so in all of the
partnership discussions I've been having
with other people I'm always slotting in
their conversations about how do we help
you be more strategic in your
investments in the community because
these large companies
and many of them you know they're the
sponsors here and other places you know
the the big big pilot conferences and
other things like that they show up but
they spend so much more money they just
throw it to the wind doing all sorts of
stuff that's ineffective and so I want
help channel those dollars to the
community and additionally I would like
for us to play a stronger role in
helping the community as well as the
commercial industry come to a better
understanding of what the value of open
innovation is and might talk after this
I think it's me upstairs I'll talk more
about the essential nature of what we've
done in open source in this community
that's very different than previous open
source kinds of efforts and communities
and why it's so essential at this point
in time especially in the machine
learning and AI space for companies to
get together and actually push open
standards forward as opposed to create
walled gardens so that's another big
hope for for me for 2020 is that we can
eat at anaconda we can use our platform
our megaphone you know just our brand to
drive some of that stuff
and this is of course just a caveat this
is assuming Western civilization
continues for another ten years right
okay so with that proviso we're not
going to model out they're kind of high
variance outcomes outside of that within
that kind of possibilities
I think Python is still remains
transgressive in many places just the
language itself right I'm on customer
calls all the time where people are
complaining look I T just doesn't get
they don't know how to manage Python
they use Python for their own shell
scripts they do some that stuff but the
application development part of IT has
no idea how to manage Python and the
weird thing I don't know how many people
are aware of this but Python is one of
the very I think it's probably the only
like top 10 language certainly the only
language that's ever made to number one
that didn't have a massive industry
business player pushing the language
that's extremely rare right so you think
about c-sharp those Microsoft write
JavaScript is pushed by the major web
developers web vendors they put so much
manpower into that and Java obviously
from Sun so Python is a community
volunteer effort that is managed to make
it to number one right I mean it's so
part of that a consequence of that is
that we have not actually had a giant
corporate marketing engine behind Python
telling IT and CIOs and managers this is
safe to use this is good to use in fact
I would say right now there is a
non-trivial number of people who would
say we will want to lean our company we
must march towards AI whatever that
means but at the same time we can't use
this open what's this open source Python
crap
right and so there are many people who
hold those two ideas in their head and
don't think they're different ideas
don't realize they're fundamentally you
know there's a contradiction there and
so to change that to change minds just
takes time and takes dollars at the end
of the day so python is still
transgressive and we have to fix that
actually in order to take over a
corporate Python however to be the
substrate for new innovation has to be I
would say innovative then maybe not
transgress but rebellious right it has
to be fun thing to continue to use
and I think the great thing about the
Python ecosystem is that you can find
your niche of cool stuff to do wherever
it is if you just want to go and build
if you want to use TV and be where do
some fun things if you want to do micro
Python in my controllers it's all there
for you
no one stopped me from using it what we
don't have is we don't have a single
unified story of Python the blah
language and this is a consequence of
pythons strengths as a glue language for
so long it's hard have a single identity
then but I think it's ok for it to be a
mixing bowl of sorts of different use
cases and different things I think
that's actually really wonderful the
challenge is if we start because now
we're mixing bowl that's number one now
everyone's going to start picking off
use cases from us right
Google is pushing Swift for tensor flow
or tensor flow Jas over here on the kind
of in with the classical system
scripting side you've got rust and go
always still there so there's like
little things on all these different
places and then the end of the day
Python doesn't run on anything with
actually user interface right so the
browser doesn't run the mobile it runs
on the backend and runs in the terminal
and because of Jupiter we have now a
presence in the web but without that
we'd really be hosed so that's kind of a
weird thing the top the top language in
the world doesn't actually have a user
interface rule to build UI is very
easily the way that you know an
equivalent way to VB in like 96 so I
think that's definitely a frontier that
we have to unlock but then beyond that I
think Python over the next 10 years if
it's to survive as a language at a meta
level it has to develop the ability to
do strategic product management and not
merely evolutionary creep along figure
out where things are because I think for
Python to go from right now Python is
like 30 to 40 million users of the I
think the estimate and the data science
use cases will continue the mluc as well
continually strong but I think for us to
get 200 million people something very
very significant and different has to
change
could you please throw some light on any
any upcoming efforts to integrate Python
and are I'm aware of our pi r pi to you
and all them is there any I've dealt
with it
several years back do you have any
anything cooking up to make it easy I'm
not doing any cooking there I know that
our studio is actively aware that our
studio is aware of the fact that python
is no longer an upstart competitor to
our but rather is now the dominant
language machine learning so I think our
studio has been making efforts to try to
be a good environment for R and Python
and to developers on these things but I
mean but there are people right I'm
thinking a few Python people there now
but the to build a good bridge any
people care about both sides equally so
I am NOT personally making investments
there I don't really I'm not much
visibility I do think that we they're
not for are specifically but inter
language Interop multi language Interop
is there are efforts in that area that I
think will help the our story as well as
many others right so obviously aro
having a unified system of data
interchange across languages helps our
helps java python all work together
better on large data sets and then the
on the front end right polyglot
interfaces almost everyone who's now
pushing out a jupiter notebook uber lab
can environment supports multiple
languages and so now you've got that so
between that and in the backend and then
some basic fa5 kinds of calling
abilities it's like probably 65 to 85
percent good enough sorry I don't have a
stronger answer but that's kind of how I
look at it okay and so what about M
Python for high school or data for high
school you have like any tool do you
recommend or because I think there is a
big gap there that is
since in high school the kids or the
people don't know what is programming or
Python or data science even leaving this
well so from a tooling perspective I
think notebooks are very friendly format
for doing this kind of thing and people
have built literate programming and
instructional materials around this kind
of stuff if you look at data camp for
instance you look at Kaggle has all
these different folks have environments
that are very friendly web-based right
Google is leaning very strong with
collab and I'm sure I don't know if it's
available in Google educational suite
yet but it certainly it would an obvious
thing to make available there so from a
tooling perspective and also we're aware
of many people in the high school high
school level just doing the standard
thing of gallilee anaconda and doing
something locally but of course not in a
school computer lab you know that can
get cumbersome because such a large
install so for for the basic tooling I
think some of the notebook based stuff
is is like kind of okay kind of good
enough now there's two more things
beyond that though so there's basic
tooling then there's conceptual
frameworks right because you're right
they're not software developers and
actually most data scientists will never
become software developers salford
element is is is a very much deeper and
bigger set of concerns than using a
language to communicate quantitative
reasoning then basically glorified
calculator right and I think that's a
really important thing people for people
to keep in mind the separation between
you know I can use Python to go and make
Dropbox or Instagram or I can use Python
ago and like clobber the CSV file those
are very - very
oh how about alright cool those are very
very different ESA's yep
one second here those are very different
use cases and we should teach them
differently and I don't know how much
sort of teach the teacher there is
around this stuff right cuz you can
absolutely see some high school
instructor who's got tons of other stuff
that she needs to worry about and she
goes and she starts trying to do a
standard CS introductory curriculum when
she should be teaching a data science
introductory curriculum those are very
different things because if you're doing
computer science programming what you're
teaching people is not so much the
language as much as how to reason about
iterated systems and the internals of a
virtual machine the the operating system
underneath the network and all this
other kind of stuff if you're using data
science you want people to reason about
the structure schema meaning of data and
how to bring all of this computational
firepower to that problem
those are two completely different
things it's like English for writing
legal documents versus English for like
poetry these are different Englishes
even though it's all English and I think
that awareness needs to be really driven
home I would encourage any and all of
you every one of you to keep that in
mind and please repeat that idea to
people because a lot of people don't
know right a lot of people simply don't
know they're like it's programming now
I'm a coder it's like you're you're
scripting a bunch of stuff that's
different that is code but it's
different code than actually going
building giant you know class
abstractions and type hierarchies and
the third thing though very long answer
but the third thing that's missing for
instruction for a lot of these folks is
this idea I think to be effective in
teaching people complete newbies the
power of computers what you want to do
is actually not teach them just how to
code that's like teaching people to cook
by teaching them how to measure
different greedy ins out stur apply heat
here or how to fricassee something but
you actually have to teach them to enjoy
the taste of food you have to give them
the why when we teach people things and
this is a general problem in pedagogy in
general here in the modern day but when
we teach you all the code for doing
analysis we have to teach them the why
and get them excited about it you have
to close the loop I can write this thing
and this makes this car do this cool
thing I can write this thing now oh I
know something about my local city
County something I didn't know before so
giving people the desire before you
teach them before you give them a fish
or teach them how to fish let them taste
a bit of fish and sound delicious that
is I love to eat foods them very nice
metaphor for me but but do you see I'm
saying like it's really important
because if all we do is teach people the
rote technique even if they're good at
doing the rote technique of data
analysis yeah how we really taught them
right I think it's really important then
for Python in order to get to that you
know I think to James's questions about
the next 10 years for Python to be
powerful or the next 10 years it has to
be the language in the environment in
which people can taste that delicious
taste of control of I can use a computer
to extend my ideas and that requires a
lot of additional development from a
framework perspective for Python it
should be easy to run the browser easy
to share easy to visualize stuff it
should be easy to drive little robotic
things it should be easy to go and talk
to massive datasets all these things
need to be easy because then I can
actually get a flavor of why this is
really awesome so next question hi I
work in a small business so we don't
have nearly the resources either
financial or people that a large
business would but we're still heavily
dependent upon all the things in the PI
data ecosystem what do you wish that
small businesses would be doing more of
to help support the community so small
businesses I would hope you have a
shorter decision-making stack right that
there's a it's it's just a smaller Beast
so the neural structure is smaller and
so if you think of if you say hey here's
a really important thing I think that we
should do that idea can go up a fewer
fewer levels of Management and back
right and that's I would say probably
the most differentiating aspect you know
small business in a big business a big
business is just every stack every level
the stack you add you add more politics
and then the message from an innovator
from a doer a person you know down in
the trenches that gets lost up the chain
in a small business hopefully you don't
have that as much
and you can then make the same points
that we make in the big business but
have a greater chance of success right
you can say look if we actually what are
the values we care about as a business
and then match those to the values to
why we want to support the open source
community right if you're a big business
for instance I'll give you a couple of
concrete examples for a big business we
tell them hey you should show up at one
of these community events because it's a
great representation you can hire even
higher data scientists and hire really
cool devs and things like that so it's a
great recruiting technique and a big
business we'll make a decision well how
much marketing how much budget to
allocate for recruiting how much budget
so and so forth and they make this big
like numerical play on a spreadsheet
because ultimately they want to hire
like a hundred data scientists right and
they want to solve that problem if your
small business maybe only hiring one or
two or maybe you have a few data
scientists but you want them to to stay
more loyal to the company and to feel
like hey the company's invested in my
career growth and me growing my skills
and so then you're solving for a much
smaller set of things and then you can
say well I'll send you let's get it to
where you can go and submit some talks
right and you show up at these
conferences and by the way you talk to
the business owners and say we should
invest and sponsor this conference a
little bit so that you know the people
so if we need to hire whatever like we
only need to hire like one or two people
we don't need to try to figure out a
strategy for hundred people so it can be
you can be much smaller dollar amounts
but also much more tactical like that
other ways the other another thing is if
you say well look we don't have very
many IT people we don't have very many
software deaths we're trying to get a
lot done with skeleton Krew we really
need this stuff to be stable because of
this thing blows up or that feature
disappears we are hosed right so how do
we do that how do we affect those
communities well we need to actually get
our folks to spend a bit of their time
interacting with that we'd have one
person on the team that maybe they're a
third or a quarter of the time at least
as spent keeping touches with the open
source communities of the core projects
we use so they're abreast of what
changes are coming they can actually put
some feedback so hey can you guys please
hold hold off another hour see just now
cuz you know this thing is actually
breaking a unit test case we have right
that kind of thing it's about having
control agency over your title
future and now beam argument I would
make kind of a mini CTO level right as a
recommendation
besides that showing up in the local
community is really really powerful
right you don't have to sponsor global
high data and give Hana my need and um
focus although if you can that'd be
great but sir but sponsoring just being
a regular sponsor for the local
community is a very powerful thing and
it's much more cost effective so those
are some concrete ideas Peter I think
it's a great idea of talking about Numb
focus and how small businesses can
support them as well
I would probably aligned myself with
those comments I think that's great I
would mention even just sending a team
to a PI data conference every ticket
donation is money that gets put back
into these projects right so hopefully
that's a mutual win-win you guys get
that and hopefully a cool conference and
money gets put through the projects can
you comment a little bit about the
rising of vs code especially in the
community of data scientists which is
somehow competing with let's say troop
their lab and some the ecosystem of
Twitter yeah I think the front end
IDE sort of competition is been
interesting to watch I don't know how it
all shake I don't really know how it
will shake out I I'll just say a few
things since I've been programming since
like ninth 86 and dev tools are a
notoriously difficult space to build a
business in Borland Borland is excellent
and they got destroyed Microsoft IBM
made eclipse and yet JetBrains IntelliJ
still kind of won their to some extent
to some of the clips I still use a lot
but but JetBrains does very well
JetBrains is like a rare exception right
in the deft holding space but there's
just not that many players and the
reason is because developers are cheap
developers do not want to spend money on
tools if there's a free thing over here
and if the thing is deficient and also
very picky and the thing is deficient in
any way they're gonna roll up their
sleeves and spend a weekend building
some kludgy little thing that's actually
worse but because they built it the
thing is awesome right and so you know
I'm saying like it's really
hard to sell tools to people who can
then build their own tools so so that's
just a very difficult in the fact that
we the fact that Jupiter was successful
it's this rare blossom in the forest
right that a new thing came around it
was successful and and keep in mind
Jupiter was not the only thing in this
space spider is still very popular still
exists and still has I believe Quan site
is funding development there so there's
there's I guess my point was gonna be
development tools are notoriously
finical finicky and fickle space to try
to compete in the fact that Jupiter was
successful should not be seen as the
beginning of a new trend but perhaps as
a one-off and it should be only natural
to expect that all of the people with
tons of dollars will start flooding into
the market to try to capture the develop
to capture the code or interest whether
the developers are data scientist to
capture that coding interest and rope
them into their walled gardens and so I
don't if you've seen that the latest
sage maker release it's gorgeous it
looks really wonderful right vs code is
very nice and vehicles very open CHT
makers of course closed but there's
tools that we've I mean collab right is
there at Google and it really it's very
nicely integrated with entire Google of
GCP environment so I think this is this
is a little unfortunate but it's a
natural thing that happens if the
open-source community
if the community of the users actually
cares to maintain an open system here I
think there's no free lunch you have to
pay devs user experience doesn't come
for free product management doesn't free
Docs design integration all of these
things I mean you're literally building
engines are software that stuff doesn't
come for free
someone's got to come up with the
dollars and the core Jupiter team for a
long time tried to figure out how to
fund it through donations from different
institutes and grants and all these
other kinds of things and you know you
can do that for a hundred years and
it'll be a fraction of Microsoft's
marketing budget for one year right and
so I think this is this then ties into
again some stuff we'll talk about my
next session the open-source community
needs to actively be cognizant of the
fact that it is now a very delicious
fish in an ocean
full of sharks and how is this little
fleshy fish gonna build a hardshell
so actually defends its values or will
just kind of be you know Ren you know
rendered into two meals for all of these
other folks there's a very brutal istic
way of describing it but that is how I
see it because I think there's something
very powerful in everyone in this room
being able to make a notebook and share
with each other regardless of what
operating system you're using regardless
of which cloud you want to use a
particular thing on having open
standards actually really matters a lot
right and then that means that one of
you can build one extension and that
would apply to all of you as opposed to
you have to build a microsoft extension
you have to build a sage maker extension
you have a thing that can only be shared
on a collab and only with certain gmail
login credentials and it won't work in
certain places in Europe you know for
whatever reason so that's that's BS we
don't want that for a computational
future however to have these open
standards takes intentional hard work
and the level of that effort has to be
impedance matched with the level
competitive interest from commercial
vendors you talked about corporate talk
about small businesses what what
government government I saw in the
conference full of government people how
everyone loves Python everyone applauded
when the Python was was was mentioned
however at the same site it's a time
when you talk to the government people
they're afraid of Python because what's
this open source coming into our systems
how does it the cond approach it and
what you see in the future for that can
you help me parse that question a little
bit better when you say everyone in
government loves it and yet everyone's
afraid of it most things I love I'm not
afraid of so what is that so it depends
who you talk to so it's like when the
name is mentioned publicly everyone
loves it but then when you talk to
people this is a talk to people on the
on the table then you figure out oh we
have security issues we have all sorts
of other problems so they don't
necessarily see the Python in the same
eyes once you know once you are once you
talk to them one to one yeah okay so I
want to make a bunch of really
controversial statements all in a row so
well they're not really that
controversial so you know the idea of
crossing the chasm it's not
controversial right
more like this is Jeffrey Moore yeah
across the chasm and that I do have like
innovators early adopters
there's the chasm and then there's the
mainstream adoption early and late
majority and laggards and the way that
this works is that different people have
different views of their own ability to
lean in to change in technological
innovation so the innovators are the
people who are like I'm gonna download
it compile it myself and try to make
this thing work because I can do it I
believe my own ability to do it like you
would never you know decompress a
tarball of code if you didn't think you
could actually compile it and use it all
right that'd be insane so like I'm not
gonna order a box full of airplane parts
because I don't know how to put it
together I would rather just buy an
airplane so from that perspective that's
that's really what separates these two
halves and then the mainstream adoption
part you have companies who actually
don't have confidence in their ability
to implement technology and technology
change so most large institutions I
would say institutions in the world
America is actually on the forefront you
go to Europe it's the situation is
dramatically worse right and there's
other places in the world it's much
worse despite all of our thing about oai
is gonna take over everything as
Skynet's Cummings all other stuff most
of the world can't even build a web
server right so the institutions the
institutions most these institutions
they know they're bad at technology and
especially in big publicly traded
companies here in America government
institutions where they've had to
basically outsource a bunch of stuff to
piles of consultants is basically a jobs
program that's one got over 20 years
that basically institutions have sucked
at owning their technological future but
that's been okay because it was the era
of monoculture the wind telma not but
duopoly you build some stuff in c-sharp
you build some stuff in java you deploy
it you do some stuff and everything is
basically 1/10
1000's as powerful as it could be and
you're wasting a bunch of money but no
one cares because everyone else is
equally bad what's happening now with
the rise of data science machine
learning all's other stuff is that in
order to cross this chasm you've got to
learn to swim you can't just sit here in
the hot tub and say I'm a swimmer you've
got to actually swim to get to
other side of this adaptive Ally and
most of these companies are ill-equipped
to do that there are there's an
awareness of that however and people are
starting I mean just turning about four
years ago I think there's a broad
awareness people are starting to make
that transition but all of these
institutions that are that have been
basically just coasting for so long they
have to make a hard decision and
actually a really someone I won't name
but but he's a big big shot technologist
to Microsoft he described it as the
impending mass extinction event because
there's a lot of businesses that are not
right across that chasm now to your
actual question about what do we do with
these government institutions at the end
of the day we are just technologists and
creators we can't we're not corporate
management consultants right you don't
own a whole bu at McKinsey to go and
backup a bus of consultants to go and
help reform these governed institutions
so you have to basically understand the
top of the topological space of what
you're trying to affect change within
they're not going to be able to change
how they view technology overnight and
so in that case you actually have to
think about productizing your services
and think about how do I take this
change put it in a in a brown paper bag
and vend this in a way that's manageable
and understandable to these people on
this other side so I would almost say to
them if they're afraid of Python then
stop talking to them about Python talk
to them about AI because they love AI
right it just turns out you can use a
pile of Python that's what's in that's
what's in the box but you you just sell
them I'm saying like take the gift wrap
paper and just say which wrapping paper
do I need write is a big data paper
here's the big data paper it's still
Python inside it right with some desk is
it AI paper here's the AI a paper it was
the same stuff inside um at some point
and I think most people here you're here
because you're here on a weekend so me
nice day you're here on a weekend
because you want to learn your learner's
you want to lean into learning more
stuff you're creators and innovators
right that's awesome most people in the
world are not that in and worse most
institutions in the world are not that
so you it's good we should always try to
lean in and and try to get people to
teach we should always try to teach but
also recognize there is still a fun
mental there's just a the medium itself
resisted change so at some point you
have to say you know what I can't teach
everybody within this org
I just got to vend something to them and
have a point of demarcation right you
then to the point of your customers
ignorance and that's just what it is
Peter thank you for your willingness to
share controversial statements with us
we out of time no I was gonna just pick
you back and say are there any other
controversial statements you want to
share with the group here no that's
that's all I have has a no yeah so she
had her hand up thank you
I'm Lily and I appreciate letting us
pick your brain thank you I am wondering
if you have thoughts or experiences with
governance structures for open-source
projects I do but is there anything in
particular that you want to ask about or
a particular problem you let me speak to
I have the opportunity to try and
improve our governance structure right
now for our project as I'm trying to
kind of crowdsource experiences okay can
I ask you to come to my next session yes
I think because I there's a whole
infrastructure of thought behind kind of
that that is exactly that question and
I'll speak to that that's basically the
content my next talk thank you hi if
anaconda didn't exist today and you had
to create it once again from scratch
today what would you do differently
so if anaconda didn't exist and you mean
the Condor technology stack the hundreds
of millions of packages in our crowd
services all these things didn't exist
today and I had to recreate it today
what would I try to accomplish with it
or why would I create it what would you
do differently comparing to the first
iteration well what I would do
differently well it's it's hard to know
what's being held constant I want to I
want to really think about this so let's
assume then
that people were using Python
successfully and there was open
innovation still being done and it
wasn't just you're using ms Python or
you know AWS Python with only AWS as you
know deep learning stuff and their
versions of their wheels only I think
you know actually so here's the fun
thing the right way to build a business
is to ask that question every day right
there's only so much of the business
that is the sustaining momentum of what
you've done before but you don't ever
want to be on a ballistic trajectory you
should always be asking okay today what
changed from yesterday and what's new
what should we do today
so I basically asked that question every
day but not what the if anaconda didn't
exist but with you know of course an
existing if everything else were the
same and I don't know I think I would be
pushing on the same things I mean that's
- I'm sorry like the the question the
answer is kind of not controversial or
surprising but I would I would continue
to try to establish open standards
between some of these competing I think
there were still be this tension of
different cloud vendors what's coming
down the pike in all the stuff is new
kinds of chips a lot of inference chips
a lot of vector processors that will
completely vulcanize the technology
space and I want to I would try to build
things that actually pull that together
I would also try to push for many many
more people learning how to use these
kinds of tools and learn these
technologies and learn the modes of
thought of quantitative thinking I would
continue doing that too I mean those are
all just those are the things I would do
I would just have to do completely
differently because I would be starting
not sitting here at anaconda but doing
you know from a different place but it
would be hard I mean there is a history
clear there's a hysteresis in all these
things it's a complex space there's a
hysteresis to the face state evolution
so what that means is that if anaconda
didn't exist we probably would have a
balkanized set of wheels on all these
different places everyone have install
hell I mean it just would be terrible
and then people if they want to create
if you want to basically
do some new computer vision thing with a
drone and some other stuff you'd have to
pick which cloud vendors captive IOT
walled garden which chips which drones
which things and then you build one tiny
little thing you put five years of your
life into building a really cool thing
and then only a tiny fraction of the
market could use it when entirely the
entire market could have used it if it
wasn't all vulcanized into little walled
gardens so once it's balkanized that way
though breaking all those walls and
uniting people especially with corporate
interests or trying to keep it within
those walls it's much harder than if we
didn't have those walls to start with
that's what I mean by the hysteresis so
I don't need actually given that if that
was the state of the world I don't know
that I would go into that because that
would just be too hard I mean I've got
an actual life to live I got kids I mean
I got stuff to do right so I would just
be angry about it a lot yeah other
questions
they can open no technical question how
do you balance your life a CEO and the
balance with your family so how is that
working for you how or how well is it
working for me okay I'm pretty tired I
mean and I don't really do very much
outside of work and then spend time with
the kids and also my wife is amazing and
she she picks up a lot of the slack but
otherwise yeah I mean I don't I wouldn't
say have a particularly good solution to
that right now I just work a lot and
yeah it's it's it's probably not
sustainable in the long run but I just I
do I mean that's all I do is just like
kids and home or work and that's just
that
so you mentioned one particular you
mentioned the sharks one shark of
interest to some people in this
community would be the the difficulty of
working with Bloomberg at times and
they've exposed through CMP and through
PLP of some of those tools but what is
your perspective of working with them
going forward when they've had open
opening dissatisfaction with with
anaconda for seemingly no reason other
than it basically allows the community
you know I mean the community of traders
I'm afraid sorry I don't quite know that
I know the context or the question can
you can you clarify just that a little
bit we've been openly hostile with them
Bloomberg has been openly hostile with
you oh really yeah
is that like they never said anything to
me about it
so the way I've described is so I
consult a lot with with what I would
call quantitative traders uh-huh and
they use Bloomberg as their data feeds
sure and so you're you go through this
process of your hey we need to set up
this environment for a quantitative
environment let's just use quant let's
just use anaconda and then some of your
additional tools we'll follow through
automatically there we would really not
like you to use anaconda and we would
expose that conversation okay there
convert and so this is through over and
over conversations where I'm like
working as a vendor to support support
quantitative traders okay so it's not
like a strategic thing it may be some or
maybe it's dodgy I have no case oh we
should talk offline about that because
like we've seen it so we've seen a
situation in the past where people want
their own Python environment they want
control over it I think as Ria's a great
example right so ArcGIS has embedded arc
PI for a long time they had their own
build that don't build a dumb high Syfy
and also their stuff and then it took an
internal movement for a while for them
people internally reckoned we need to
use anaconda with this everyone in the
community was like we would love to use
anaconda inside ArcGIS and so it just
took a little while for that for the
mindsets to change there if it's okay if
it's basically just a product
integration kind of issue then
the way to do that is actually just have
a deeper partnership conversation and I
know people at Bloomberg and we can try
to maybe break some ground there and I'd
love to you know talk to me afterwards
I'd love to know a little bit more about
that yeah Travis as well those people
they're their babies peeps of people
that are talking to you from their
bosses maybe what's right Travis will
make it happen
yeah why do we be the basis but advice
you can give about leadership
the best advice about leadership is I
will paraphrase Mad Men that leadership
consists of three things
vision loyalty and experience or wisdom
but you need all three things and
ultimately my view on leadership is that
leadership is service and that's not
everyone's view on it some people run
differently I've done a lot of this is
this it's a great question it's I love
this topic but I've just written so many
notes and had so many thoughts about it
it's all flooding in it's like getting
bottle necked I would say that that's
the the thing I would start with is this
idea that vision loyalty and wisdom or
experience at the end of the day a
leader of an organization or movement
they have to create some people say
dispel disbelief that the first job of a
leader is to dispel disbelief others say
that is to create belief either way it's
kind of the same thing but at all that
all goes to the vision bit right you
have to tell people we're gonna go there
and people are like well we're not there
now and we've never been there how do we
know we can get there right ultimately
if you're leading people it has to be
about that and and that's just the
fundamental thing so when people talk
about Steve Jobs and they disparage his
reality distortion field that's just
what it feels like to be in an
environment where someone has strong
leadership
now cult leaders have the same thing but
they're strong leaders right I wouldn't
say I would follow them but that's
strong leadership so anyway that's
yeah thank you
what's been the most frustrating thing
you've seen in the Python community in
the last like five or 10 years how much
no five minutes all right one per year
the most frustrating thing well it
varies because my skin's gotten thicker
over time so stuff that would have
totally riled me up five years ago I'm
just like yeah I think ultimately it's
done in Kruger so there are a lot of
really really smart geeks who don't
realize what they don't know about
everything else that it takes to move a
community forward a lot of people you
know actually Douglas Adams wrote in his
book last chance to see I think it was
he had this parable of the pond
that wakes up in the morning and it's
like wow what an amazing world what a
benevolent creators have made a hole
just the right shape for me and this is
amazing right everything is just right
for me to be here I think there's some
people in the Python community who have
no idea of what dug the hole that gave
them their opportunity right now and
they're not aware then of the risks to
that so I think for me right now well
the most frustrating thing for me right
now is probably the most frustrating
thing over the last period of time and
and it's it's that Python has managed to
do something absolutely incredible
I just cannot I cannot sing enough
praises of what people in the community
and that's all the numb focus people
here again here on a weekend and they do
this all the time and they're flying
away from families to go and do
essentially rallying of an of a
community of volunteers right people who
have to argue with their managers to get
time and budget to travel and we've
built this because we care and so it's a
community that cares about a technology
and technology impact thing that's
actually really rare in technology I
mean I'm a physicist by training I
didn't try to be a software entrepreneur
cuz that's why I was gonna do I mean I
end up kind of in the industry
accidentally and I've gotten just more
more cynical about industries I've acted
with it more but it's like holy crap
there's like everything that's that's
popular and worth hundreds of billions
of dollars it's actually made it's built
not with those values and so we have
here a community an ecosystem a verdant
you know Elvan Glade that's amazing and
everything else is like concrete jungles
and crap and yet the community that
built this some of them just live in a
cave underground and they don't have any
idea of why everything's so awesome and
why everything will soon cease to be
awesome if they don't actually lean into
owning their destiny that's the most
frustrating thing like if we were just
hobbits in the Shire always living in
our holes and never having a shot at
glory fine but we have like we've not
just had a shot at glory we're it now
we're we are Mordor right but we are
well ok this kind of went off the rail
we're the dominant thing and that is
such a rare moment to have that that
platform and have a network an ecosystem
of generativity a rise to that level we
got to do something with it and yet
there's still people in the community
who just just floating along like a
little pond right the holes just the
hole feels good for me right now this is
great and that's really frustrating for
me we're not more - please scratch don't
tweet that
I think we have just a few more minutes
do you have any closing thoughts or I
can throw it out for one more question
all the question last question what is
your most controversial opinion about
the Python ecosystem I could tell you
but I would have to tribute to Steve
dower my most controversial opinion
about the Python ecosystem I don't know
I mean actually there's just so many I
don't know I'd say there's a lots what
just one well I mean I may be the most
controversial maybe it's actually not
that kinda here's the thing it's
actually not the most controversial but
probably the least understood by
everyone is that product management for
the Python language has basically
stalled in my opinion that we are in
maintenance mode on language features
and things like that and maybe my most
controversial opinion building on that
is that that's okay ooh and maybe that's
okay and so whereas you know 18 months
ago I'd have been like super care mad
maybe I'm like you know what maybe this
is actually the natural order of things
and it's to be a stable foundation for
what comes next
I think we all really appreciate Peter
coming out here
share your thoughts can we give them a
round of applause for you thank you
everyone
[Applause]